so we've plotted two complex numbers
right over here on this argon diagram
and what I want to think about is what
if we define a third complex number C as
being equal to the complex number a
minus the complex number B what is C
going to look like if we were to write
it as just a sum of its real and
imaginary parts and what would it look
like on this Argand diagram so let's
just first think about this so C is let
me do that yellow color C is equal to a
which is the same thing as 6 plus 2i 6
plus 2i minus minus B and what is B B is
2 minus I so when we're subtracting
anything we can distribute this negative
sign and so this would be the same thing
this would be equivalent to 6 plus 2i
minus 2 minus 2 and then distributing
the negative on a negative I that's
going to be a positive I plus I just
like that and now this is going to be
equal to this is going to be equal to
let me I'll do it right over here this
is going to be equal to we could add R
we can add the real parts right over
here we have 6 minus 2 and so that's
going to be 4 and then we can add then
we can add the 2 I to the I which is
going to be 3 eyes plus 4 plus 3i and
that is the complex number C now let's
see why that actually makes sense when
we look when we view when we visualize a
and B as vectors so this is B but what
we're essentially when we do a minus B
that's essentially the same thing that's
the same thing as a plus negative B a
plus negative B so what's negative B
going to be equal to negative B is going
to be equal to negative 2
plus I I just I just multiplied all the
terms by negative 1 so what does that
look like let's see negative 2 negative
2 plus I gets us right over there and we
see we've essentially we've essentially
just flipped this vector over the origin
so this right over here is negative B
that is negative B and we've already
seen if you're adding two things we're
going to add a to negative B so we go
we've plotted a so that it's as tails at
the origin its head is right over here
and then we could take the tail of B we
take the tail of negative B put it right
over here and then if you just shift it
over it's going to be let's go to to the
left and one up two to the left and one
up it gets to that point right over here
it gets to this point right over there
so that is this vector is another way to
visualize negative B is a as a vector
and so we're our new head is once we put
the tail of negative B here where our
new head is is going to be the head of
our vector C so C is going to be this
vector right over here C is going to be
this vector right over here can be
visualized as this vector right over
here and we see that is 1 2 3 4 that is
4 plus 1 2 3 I we see that right over
there so on one level it's kind of you
know straightforward manipulating
expressions and just recognizing that
you can only add the imaginary parts to
the imaginary parts and the real parts
to the real parts and if you want to
visualize it on an Argand diagram it
really is analogous to adding
subtracting B from a is equivalent to
adding the negative of B to a